>> Sean: SO AS YOU KNOW BY NOW,
ROSEANNE BARR TWEETED OUT SOME
INAPPROPRIATE OVER-THE-LINE
REMARKS ABOUT VALORIE JARRETT.
IN RESPONSE, WE NOW THAT ABC
CANCELLED THE REBOOT OF
"ROSEANNE."
TONIGHT I'M GOING TO RESPOND TO
ROSEANNE BARR'S TWEET AND THE
DOUBLE STANDARD IN THIS COUNTRY
WHERE CONSERVATIVES ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE WHILE THOSE ON THE
LEFT NEVER SEEM TO FACE
CONSEQUENCES FOR RACISM, BIGOTRY
OR SEXISM.
THAT'S TONIGHT'S IMPORTANT MINI
MONOLOGUE.
WE KNOW THIS WEEK ROSEANNE BARR
RIGHTLY APOLOGIZED FOR HER
TERRIBLE COMMENTS ABOUT VALORIE
JARRETT.
SHE SAID NOBODY SHOULD DEFEND
HER IN LIGHT OF WHAT HAPPENED.
SHE WAS RIGHT TO APOLOGIZE.
BUT I WOULD ARGUE THAT WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT THIS MOMENT AND DO
BETTER AS A COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO RESPECT ALL RACES,
ALL CREEDS, ALL BACKGROUND.
ROSEANNE IS A PUBLIC FIGURE AND
HER COMMENTS HURT INNOCENT
PEOPLE AND SHE'S FACING
CONSEQUENCES.
SHE CAN SAY IT ON HER OWN TIME
BUT ABC HAS THEIR OWN DECISION
MAKING.
WE SHOULD FEEL BAD.
A LOT OF INNOCENT PEOPLE LOST
THEIR JOBS.
THEY HAVE FAMILIES, MORTGAGES,
RENT PAYMENTS, CAR PAYMENTS AND
OTHER EXPENSES.
COLLEGE KIDS TO WORRY ABOUT.
OF COURSE, ROSEANNE IS NOT THE
FIRST PUBLIC FIGURE TO MAKE
OUTRAGEOUS COMMENTS AND SHE
ADMITS THAT SHE'S BEEN HELD
RIGHTLY ACCOUNTABLE.
SO MANY DESPICABLE COMMENTS AND
ACTIONS ON THE LEFT GO
UNNOTICED, A HUGE DOUBLE
STANDARD.
MANY GET A FREE PASS, INCLUDING
A FORMER WRITER THAT IS ON
ROSEANNE'S SHOW.
WANDA SYKES.
REMEMBER SHE ANNOUNCED SHE WAS
QUITTING THE SHOW TO PROTEST
ROSEANNE'S TWEET?
SYKES HAS HAD RACIAL TWEETS
INCLUDING THIS ONE.
WHITE PEOPLE DON'T STEAL
WALLETS, THEY STEAL COUNTRIES.
SHE NEVER HAD ANY CAREER-ENDING
BACKLASH FROM THAT TWEET.
HOW ABOUT ANOTHER ABC EMPLOYEE?
JIMMY KIMMEL.
HE WAS ON COMEDY CENTRAL.
HE DRESSED UP IN BLACK FACE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> HELLO, EVERYBODY OUT THERE IN
TV TOWN.
THIS IS KARL MALONE OF THE UTAH
JAZZ HERE TO TELL YOU ABOUT KARL
MALONE HOME STATE, LOUISIANA.
SOMETIME AT NIGHT KARL MALONE
WILL LOOK UP IN THE SKY AND SAY,
WHAT THE HELL GOING ON UP THERE?
THE UFO ON OTHER PLANETS?
PHONE HOME LIKE ET?
KARL MALONE NEVER SEEN NO FLYING
SAUCER HIT THE SHELF.
IF HE DO, THAT WILL BE A SPEAKY
TIME.
>> Sean: ABC'S CEO, BOB IGER
PUTS JIMMY KIMMEL ON NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT.
WE CAN'T FORGET ABOUT HIS SEXIST
SKITS THAT HE DID.
MIGHT REMEMBER THIS.
>> HELLO.
WELCOME TO HOLLYWOOD.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE SEX
ME?
>> NO.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE SEX?
NO?
PLEASE?
I'M BEGGING YOU.
I THINK YOU WOULD ENJOY IT.
HIS UNIT IS RELATIVELY SMALL.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT.
>> GIVES YOU THIS INADEQUACY
THING.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> YOU HAVE TEN SECONDS TO THEN
GUESS WHAT IS IN MY PANTS.
READY?
SET?
>> GO.
>> YOU SHOULD USE TWO HANDS.
TWO HANDS.
>> Sean: NO ONE AT ABC, BOB IGER
OR DISNEY IS OUTRAGED BY THAT?
OF COURSE, YOU HAVE JOY BEHAR.
SHE ATTACKED MIKE PENCE.
WHY?
BECAUSE OF HIS CHRISTIAN FAITH.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> SHE SAID THAT JESUS TELLS
MIKE PENCE THINGS TO SAY.
>> WHEN WAS SHE AROUND MIKE
PENCE THOUGH?
>> OBVIOUSLY SHE WAS AROUND HIM.
WHEN YOU HAVE A MIKE PENCE THAT
PUTS THIS RELIGIOUS VENEER ON
THINGS AND CALLS PEOPLE VALUES
VOTERS
VOTER
VOTERS, WE'RE IN A DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
I'M CATHOLIC.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I WANT MY VICE
PRESIDENT SPEAKING IN TONGUES.
>> LIKE HE SAID BEFORE IT'S ONE
THING TO TALK TO JESUS.
IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN JESUS
TALKS TO YOU.
>> EXACTLY.
THAT'S DIFFERENT.
>> THAT'S MENTAL ILLNESS IF I'M
NOT CORRECT.
HEARING VOICES.
>> MY QUESTION IS CAN HE TALK TO
MARY MAGDALINE IF SHE'S IN THE
ROOM.
>> Sean: BEHAR STILL WORKS FOR
ABC.
SHE WAS FORCED TO APOLOGIZE.
AND NEXT UP, KEITH OBERMAN IS
BACK.
TRUMP HATING.
BOB REHIRED HIM.
HE TWEETED TELL YOUR RACIST
WHITE SUPREMACIST NEO-NAZI
FATHER TO GET THE BLEEP OUT OF
OUR SOCIETY.
HE TARGETED JOE ARPAIO SAYING
"YOU AND POTUS CAN GO BLEEP
YOURSELVES, YOU RACIST NAZI
BLEEP."
YEAH, IGER JUST HIRED HIM TO GO
BACK TO ESPN.
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
NOW WE TURN OUR ATTENTION TO NBC
NEWS.
LAST NIGHT THEY RAN A SPECIAL
ENTITLED EVERY DAY RACISM IN
AMERICA.
JOY REED CAME UNDER FIRE FOR
OUTRAGEOUS BLOG POSTS.
SHE CLAIMS WITHOUT PROOF THAT
THE INTERNET HAD BEEN HACKED A
AND THE FIRESTORM GOES AWAY.
EVERYBODY ON THE LEFT ACCEPTED
WHAT WAS REALLY A BIZARRE
EXPLANATION.
NBC FREQUENTLY FEATURES THE
REVEREND AL SHARPTON ON ISSUES
OF RACE AND SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THE SAME AL SHARPTON.
YOU MAY REMEMBER HE SAID ALL OF
THESE THINGS.
>> YOU AIN'T NOTHING.
YOU'RE A PUNK [BLEEP].
COME AND DO SOMETHING.
>> WE'RE THE BLACK CHICKEN FRIED
OF THE UNIVERSE.
>> Sean: HE'S WORKS FOR NBC
WHICH FEATURES ALEC BALDWIN IN
ORDER TO MAKE FUN OF THE
PRESIDENT ON "SATURDAY NIGHT
LIVE," DESPITE BALDWIN'S -- HE
HAS A TEMPER PROBLEM.
REMEMBER THIS?
>> YOU HEAR WHAT I SAID?
ANSWER ME.
YES OR NO.
>> YES.
>> YOU HEAR WITH MY WIFE AND KID
OUT HERE.
YOU HAVE A BIG PROBLEM, DON'T
YOU?
>> YOU ARE AS DUMB AS YOU LOOK.
YOU ARE WITH FOX, RIGHT?
>> YOU WANT TO APOLOGIZE ON
CAMERA?
I ASKED YOU A QUESTION.
GET THE [BLEEP] OUT OF HERE.
>> I'M LEAVING THIS SPECIAL WITH
YOU TO TELL YOU, YOU HAVE
INSULTED ME FOR THE LAST TIME.
YOU HAVE INSULTED ME.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE BRAINS OR THE
DECENCY AS A HUMAN BEING.
I DON'T GIVE A [BLEEP] THAT
YOU'RE 12 YEARS OLD OR 11 YEARS
OLD OR THAT YOU'RE A CHILD.
SO YOU BETTER BE READY FRIDAY,
THE 20th TO MEET WITH ME BECAUSE
I'M GOING TO LET YOU KNOW HOW I
FEEL ABOUT WHAT A LITTLE PIG YOU
ARE.
>> Sean: HE WORKS FOR BOB IGER
TOO AT ABC.
OVER AT HBO, BILL MAHR SPEAKS
OUT AT LEFTIST EXTREMISM.
>> A LOT OF US THOUGHT IVANKA
WILL BE OUR SAVING GRACE, YOU
KNOW, WHEN HE'S ABOUT TO [BLEEP]
NUKE FINLAND OR SOMETHING.
SHE'S GOING TO WALK INTO THE
BEDROOM AND, YOU KNOW, DADDY,
DADDY -- DON'T DO IT, DADDY.
>> Sean: REALLY?
OKAY.
LET'S LOOK AT SOMEONE ELSE'S
LONG BEEN IN THE PUBLIC EYE.
THEY HIT THIS PICTURE.
HAD IT BEFORE THE ELECTION IN
2008.
FARRAKHAN WITH BARACK OBAMA.
GIVENING FARRAKHAN'S RACIST AND
ANTI-
ANTI
ANTI-SEMITIC PAST.
>> THEY CALL ME HITLER.
HITLER WAS A GOOD NAME.
HE WAS A GREAT MAN.
THE SATANIC JEWS, THEY CONTROL
EVERYTHING AND MOSTLY EVERYBODY.
>> BECAUSE YOU SEE WHITE PEOPLE
DESERVE TO DIE.
AND THEY KNOW, SO THEY THINK
IT'S US COMING TO DO.
KAW CAUTION MEANS WEAK BLOODED
STALE FACE.
>> Sean: SO DOES THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA THAT OBAMA ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT PERSON OR WERE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BEING DECEIVED?
THEY HIT THE TWO PEOPLE THERE
TOGETHER.
IT'S RIGHT THERE ON THE SCREEN.
AND REVEREND WRIGHT, THE PASTOR
OF THE CHURCH OF J.D. AMERICA.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
I WILL NEVER EVER CALL FOR ANY
BOYCOTTS OR ANYBODY TO BE FIRED
OR SHOW TO BE CANCELLED.
YOU HAVE THE POWER TO TURN THE
DIAL.
BUT LET ME POINT OUT A BLATANT
LEFT WING STANDARD.
WHO SUMMED IT UP BEST, SARAH
SANDERS WHEN SHE SAID THIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S POINTING TO
THE HYPOCRISY IN THE MEDIA
SAYING THE MOST HORRIBLE THINGS
ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT AND NOBODY
ADDRESSES IT.
WHERE WAS BOB IGER'S APOLOGY FOR
JOY BEYER CALLING CHRISTIANITY A
MENTAL ILLNESS?
WHERE WAS THE APOLOGY FOR KATHY
GRIFFIN GOING ON A PROFANE RANT
ON "THE VIEW" AFTER A PHOTO
SHOWED HER HOLDING PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S DECAPITATED HEAD?
WHERE WAS THE APOLOGY FOR BOB
IGER FOR ESPN AND HIRING
OLBERMAN AND CALLING THE
PRESIDENT A NAZI AND EXPANDING
THAT ATTACK AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT'S FAMILY?
NOBODY HAVE DEFENDING HER
COMMENTS.
THEY'RE INAPPROPRIATE BUT THAT'S
THE POINT HE WAS MAKING.
>> Sean: WELL-SAID, SARAH
SANDERS.
I SAID AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
MONOLOGUE.
LET'S THINK ABOUT THIS.
IT'S TIME FOR ALL AMERICANS,
REGARDLESS OF YOUR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION, YEAH, WE ALL NEED
TO DO BETTER.
WE ALL NEED TO HOLD HOURSELVES,
OUR FRIENDS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WORDS AND ACTIONS.
WE NEED TO BE 1 NATION, ONE
PEOPLE.
THIS COUNTRY WILL SUCCEED OR
FAIL TOGETHER.
IF WE'RE ATTACKED, IT'S ALL OF
US ATTACKED.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
REGARDLESS OF RACE, CREED,
COLOR, NATIONAL ORIGIN.
MY RELIGION TEACHES ME WE'RE ALL
CREATED BE I THE SAME GOD IN HIS
IMAGE.
WE CAN ALL DO SO MUCH BETTER.
WE HAVE TO BE THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
SHOULD BE EVERYBODY'S GOAL.
TOO MANY PEOPLE HAVE DIED AND
SACRIFICE FOR ALL OF US TO HAVE
LIBERTY AND FREEDOM AND WE OWE